one of the more frustrating parts of the  early game is just how quickly your  pockets will start to fill up with items  you'll be delighted to know that you can  purchase two upgrades to expand your  pockets after you've paid off your tent  i would recommend focusing on these two  upgrades you'll need to visit resident  services in the center of town and  access the computer kiosk in the corner  from here you can purchase a pocket  organization guide using nook miles five  thousand nook miles may seem expensive  but it's absolutely worth it the next  upgrade will be called ultimate pocket  stuffing and will cost 8 000 nook miles  again totally worth it trust me after a  few weeks with the game you'll have more  nook miles than you can possibly know  what to do with unless you want to go on  a crazy number of villager hunts which i  wouldn't blame you if you did after  those two upgrades you'll have four rows  with a total of 40 item slots